cut myself shaving for the 761st I'm
stupid shaving always ruining everything
good morning Hank it's Tuesday
so 2000 years ago something like half of
people died before the age of 5 1800
years later in 1800 the global
under-five mortality rate had gone from
somewhere around 50 percent all the way
down to somewhere around 43 percent but
then it began declining dramatically
like by 2013 the global child mortality
rate wasn't 50% or 43 percent it was 3.4
percent in wealthy countries it's under
1% how did this happen well in the new
annual letter from Melinda and Bill
Gates Bill argues persuasively that the
key to these big changes in health and
development was and is energy the whole
butter is fascinating you should read it
there's a link in the doobly-doo but I
want to highlight a few big points so ok
there are about 1.3 billion people who
don't have regular access to the kinds
of energy that most of us take for
granted and that has a huge impact on
their lives like without electricity
kids can't study after dark except by
candlelight and they can't access online
resources like Wikipedia without
tractors and energy intensive fertilizer
people grow less food and without
running water it's almost impossible to
sterilize health care centers so it's no
surprise that the 18% of humans living
without regular electricity are more
likely to die of preventable diseases
and malnutrition and much less likely to
have access to good schools they are
also by the way disproportionately
affected by climate change which is
especially unfair you know because by
and large they haven't experienced that
much benefit from the fossil fuel
consumption that's a big driver of
climate change for instance the average
person in Bangladesh uses 98.8% less oil
than the average American and therein
lies what I think will be the biggest
question of this century how do we get
energy solutions to the 1.3 billion
people who don't yet have them while
also dramatically reducing carbon
emissions the answer lots and lots of
people trying lots and lots of solutions
most of which will fail but a few of
which will hopefully succeed
spectacularly otherwise we're in big
trouble so way back in 1800 you probably
would have been one of the 43% of people
who didn't live to age 5 you had a bunch
of serious infections as a kid this
would have been bad news for you
obviously but it also would have been
somewhat bad news for the rest of us
because you've gone on to do some cool
stuff companies you started employ a lot
of people you've helped me and many
others understand important scientific
concepts
you invented 2d glasses which allow
people to see 3d movies in a crisp two
dimensions etc and basically advances in
health and development have allowed the
world to contain more Hanks which is
great but now we need even more of them
we need as many Hanks as we can get
because we know from history that when
lots and lots of innovators work on big
problems they find big solutions and
that leads me to the second half of this
year's gates letter which is about time
specifically how poverty is worsened by
gender disparities when it comes to time
so Melinda Gates points out that
globally women spend twice as much time
on unpaid work as men this gap is
largest in poor countries will work like
getting water chopping wood cooking and
cleaning is mostly done by women and as
melinda points out assigning most unpaid
work to women harms everyone because of
what's known as opportunity cost when
girls are walking hours every week to
get water those are hours they can't
spend in school or studying if men and
women are equally able to innovate and
create and they are gender bias
definitionally limits economic growth
gender bias isn't just wrong ethically
it means less innovation fewer jobs and
less inclusive governance to address
this problem Melinda advocates
recognizing reducing and redistributing
first we need to recognize that unpaid
work is work second we need to reduce
the time needed to do such work and
third we need to redistribute that work
more evenly between women and men Hank I
think we're gonna look back on energy
and gender equity as two of the biggest
challenges of the 21st century but right
now we're not just struggling to solve
those problems too often we're refusing
to acknowledge they exist and that has
to change now if the next 200 years are
going to continue the successes of the
previous 200 Hank I'll see you on Friday